hace un par de vídeos encontramos los
valores propios de una matriz de 2 por 2
de una matriz de 2 por 2 ahora quiero
hacer lo mismo pero con una matriz de 3
por 3 con esta matriz de aquí y espero
que se den cuenta que a pesar de que la
matemática se va a poner un poco más
pesada o un poco más enredos a la idea
que vamos a usar es exactamente la misma
así que bueno repasando un poco tenemos
que el lambda es uno
valor propio de una matriz a lambda es
un valor propio de a
sí solo sí
sí solo si existe un vector distinto de
0 tal que a por b es igual a lambda por
el vector b
esto es para algún vector de distinto de
el vector
muy bien ahora esto pasa si solo sí
lo que voy a hacer es restar ave de
ambos lados y entonces esto se convierte
en vector 0 es igual a lambda por b pero
b es lo mismo que la identidad por b así
que voy a poner aquí la matriz identidad
por el vector de menos
por el vector de y esto es para alguna
vez distinta de cero bueno pues como los
productos de matrices y vectores tienen
la propiedad distributiva esto lo puede
escribir como el vector 0 es igual a
lambda por la identidad menos
todo eso por el vector b y esta vez de
nuevo es distinta de cero
estoy haciendo estos repasos para que
entiendan bien de dónde salen las
fórmulas no me interesa que sólo se
aprendan la fórmula sino el proceso
lógico que nos llevó a la fórmula ok
déjenme voy a escribir esta parte de
aquí la voy a volver a escribir y
entonces tengo
tengo la matriz lambda por la identidad
menos a por el vector b es igual al
vector 0 y esta vez es distinta de 0 es
distinta el vector 0 así que en otras
palabras lo que estoy diciendo es que el
espacio el espacio nulo o la nulidad de
esta matriz de esta matriz y aquí todo
esto es una matriz es no trivial o dicho
de otro modo sus columnas son
linealmente dependientes o incluso dicho
de otro modo significa que la matriz no
es invertirle y eso pasa eso pasa si y
sólo si el determinante de esa matriz es
0 así que en otras palabras lambda es un
valor propio de la matriz a si y sólo si
el determinante el determinante d
lambda por la identidad menos
es igual a cero ahora vamos a usar esto
para encontrar los valores propios de
esta matriz de aquí muy bien entonces lo
primero que tengo que hacer es encontrar
la matriz lambda por la identidad como
la matriz a es de 3 por 3 tengo que usar
la identidad de 3 x 3
ahora la matriz identidad es la matriz
que tiene unos en la diagonal y 0 en
todos otros lados entonces lambda por
esa matriz simplemente sería la matriz
lambda 000 lambda 0 y 0 0 lambda la
matriz que sólo tiene al lambda en la
diagonal y hacer en todos otros lados ok
ahora quiero encontrar el determinante
determinante de la matriz lambda por la
identidad menos a y eso es lo mismo que
encontrar el determinante de la matriz
quién
qué matriz de gemelos y lambda menos 1
lambda menos -1 es lambda más uno
damas 1 luego 0 - 2 - 2
0 - 2 de nuevo es menos 2
0 - 2 - 2
lambda menos 2 lambda menos dos es la
menos dos
0 - 1 es uno positivo
0 - 2 es menos 20 menos menos 1 es uno
positivo y finalmente lambda menos 2 es
dando menos 2 ok entonces quiero
encontrar el determinante de esta matriz
y la forma más fácil de encontrar el
determinante de una matriz de 3 por 3 al
menos la que se me ocurre ahorita es
utilizar la regla desarrollo quizás
también se podría hacer por menores
vamos a usar las regresarnos nosotros
entonces lo que hago déjenme copio estas
dos columnas por dos columnas las copió
y las colocó aquí al lado
entonces las reglas de salud me dice que
para encontrar el determinante lo que
tengo que hacer es tomar las diagonales
que van descendentes así decirlo- y
tomarlas con signo positivo así que como
en todos estos elementos los multiplico
y les pongo signo positivo tomó estos
elementos los multiplicó y les pongo
signo positivo tomo estos elementos los
multiplicó y les pongo signo positivo y
luego tomo las diagonales descendentes y
les pongo signo negativo es decir tomo
estos elementos los multiplicó les pongo
signo negativo como estos elementos los
multiplicó y les pongo signo negativo y
tomo estos elementos los multiplicó y
les pongo signo negativo ok entonces
vamos a hacer los positivos primero
sería
lambda más 1 portland a menos 2 portland
a menos 2 eso sencillamente lo voy a
escribir como lo que es la onda más uno
por la banda menos dos por lambda menos
dos eso es con signo positivo menos dos
por uno por menos dos es cuatro positivo
y tiene más entonces más 4
- 2 x menos dos es cuatro positivo por
unos cuatro y de nuevo con signo + + 4
ahora bien los que voy a restar menos 2
x menos dos es cuatro positivo por landa
menos dos así que menos cuatro por
lambda menos dos recuerden que aquí les
tengo que poner el signo negativo lambda
más uno por uno por uno
eso es simplemente lambda me lambda más
uno pero con el signo menos es menos
lambda más uno
y ahora menos 2 x menos dos que es 4
positivo por la onda menos 2 con signo
menos -4 por lambda menos 2 y ahora
tengo que reducir tengo que reducir todo
esto
y lo escribo así vamos a expandir
primero todo esto este primer caso en
este caso aquí
es lo mismo que la mandamás 1
portland a menos 2 portland o al menos
dos pero eso es lambda al cuadrado menos
4 holanda más 4
simplemente haciendo todo este producto
cuatro y cuatro pues ese es ocho ya lo
pongo de una vez ahora esto menos cuatro
por lambda menos dos es menos 4 lambda
más 8
- lambda + 1 entonces me menos lambda
menos 1 el signo menos afecta es de más
menos 4 por lambda es menos 4 lambda
menos 4 x menos 238
ok ahora esta parte de aquí primero
multiplico todo por lambda y obtengo
lambda al cubo menos cuatro lambda
cuadrado
+ 4 holanda 4 lambda más
ahora es uno por esto que sería blando
al cuadrado menos 4 holanda más 4
y aquí tengo el 8
este 8 luego de que me voy reduciendo es
lo que tengo acá menos 4 lambda menos
lambda menos 4 lambda es menos nueve
lambda
9 en la vida
8 - 178 es 15
ya puede reducir todo este polinomio y
simplemente nos otro color esto se
convierte en lambda el cubo menos 4
lambda
- 4 holanda cuadrado más grande cuadrado
se vuelve menos 3 blanda cuadrado
+ 4 holanda menos 4 holanda y 0 pero acá
tengo menos 9 lambda
de los 9 lambda que me queda me falta el
término en el término independiente 4 y
8 es 4 y 8 12 + 15 es 27 más 27 así que
este es el determinante de esa matriz y
habíamos llamado a eso el polinomio
característico de la matriz lambda es
esto el determinante de esta matriz se
llama el polinomio característico y para
que sea un valor propio lambda tiene que
ser tal que esto sea igual a cero ok
entonces tengo que el polinomio
característico tiene grado 3 para
encontrar sus países los números lambda
que hagan que esto sea 0 pues existe una
fórmula existe una fórmula que es el
análogo a la fórmula cuadrática se llama
la fórmula de carga no pero es algo
complicada entonces como estamos
trabajando con un problema de una clase
de álgebra vamos a irnos con la
esperanza de
y las raíces sean números enteros o al
menos racionales como el coeficiente de
aquí como el coeficiente principal el
coeficiente del grado más alto es 1
entonces las raíces si llegan a ser
raíces enteras tienen que ser divisores
de 27 ahora cuáles son los divisores de
27 divisores de 27 pues son
13 9 y 27 y obviamente con signo
contrario menos 1 - 3 - 9 27 vamos a
probar con 1 vamos a probar primero con
el número uno si sustituyó por uno aquí
obtengo 1 - 3 - 9 + 27 y bueno ustedes
pueden checar esto es distinto de 0 así
que uno no es una raíz que hay de 3 try
de 3 pues si sustituyó aquí por 3
obtengo 3 al cubo que es 27 menos 3 por
9 de nuevos 27 menos 9 por 3 que otras
veces 27 más 27 y esto sí es
así que no es perdón así que 33 si es
una raíz de este polinomio
es raíz
muy bien si 13 raíz eso significa
recuerden que
lambda menos 3 divide a este polinomio y
entonces puedo hacer la división puedo
hacer esta división
de el polinomio holanda al cubo menos 3
landa cuadrado menos nueve lambda más 27
entre lambda menos 3 y cuánto me da eso
cuánto me va a dar eso andaba el hambre
al cubo lambda cuadrado veces así que
tengo esto ahora multiplicó y obtengo
blanda al cubo blando al cuadrado por
menos 3 es menos 3 lambda cuadrado ok
tengo que hacer esta resta éste
polinomio menos este esto se cancela
y me queda menos 9 blanda más 27
-9 lambda 27
cuántas veces balanda en -9 lambda pues
simplemente va menos nueve veces así que
menos nueve por lambda es menos 9 lambda
menos 9 por menos 3 es 27 positivo y
ahora restó estos dos y me deja residuo
cero como ya esperábamos ok entonces
entonces ahora puede escribir que mi
polinomio característico binomio
característico que era este polinomio de
aquí es igual a lambda menos 3 por
lambda al cuadrado menos 9
ahora bien lambda al cuadrado menos 9 no
puedo factorizar como
el mismo color esto es lo mismo que
lambda menos 3 y esto es una diferencia
de cuadrados este término es una
diferencia cuadrados así que lo voy a
escribir como lambda menos 3 por lambda
más 3 y de aquí de aquí concluyó
que las raíces de mi polinomio son
lambda igual a menos 3 que sería la raíz
de este factor
lambda igual a 3 noten que esto es una
raíz raíz repetida y bueno con esto ya
tengo los valores propios de mi matriz a
los valores propios
valores propios
son
- 3 y 3 y en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
calcular los vectores propios que le
corresponden a esta matriz